Hillside police.
Detective Malloy, please.
I would like to report a crime.
For those of you who don't know me, I am Doctor Birch, and this is the philosophy of language.
Daddy's home !
What are you guys still doing up?
Daddy, there's a crazy person in the woods.
What's he talking about?
Oh, girl went missing up at the lake.
Ellen Birch?
Yes?
Is your husband home?
What's this about, detective?
We got a report, a man in a gray Volvo was watching the other day she disappeared.
Can you tell me where you were?
I doubt it.
I can barely remember last week.
That was his last day of camp.
You went to pick her up, remember?
Our counselor said you waited for 40 minutes.
Is tardiness a crime?
Obstruction is.
I'm not answering another question until I speak to my lawyer.
Are you used to a case like this?
Well, do you mean a kidnapping?
Or do you mean a murder?
Did you ever meet Joyce Bonner?
I don't think so.
When a kid goes missing here, the cops need a suspect.
Coincidence put you in the crosshairs.
Cops don't ask questions.
They plant landmines.
Mrs Birch...
We found strands of Joyce's hair in your husband's car.
What was she doing in your car?
I told you, I don't remember.
This is her lipgloss, Zelda found it.
They must have planted it.
This is a lie.
She's out there and if she's still alive she's on borrowed time.
Philosophy. We're in the same bracket.
Searching for the truth.
Do you have trouble remembering things a detective can call, sequences?
You tell me.
So, there is no such thing as truth.
Can I tell you the truth or what I perceive?
You kept a secret from your wife?
Will you please calm down?
I'm sick of being calm.
I'm terrified what else you could convince yourself of.
You know me. I wouldn't hurt a fly.